ich habe einmal einen neuen video und
zwar bis heute gedacht wir machen
einfach mal dicke mädchen mädchen
extreme auszuloggen und wir haben uns
ein paar punkte mehr aufgesucht die
gibt's heute von uns wir wollen gar
nicht eingeladen bei den beiden auf dem
channel gibt es auch noch video das
dürft ihr auf keinen fall verpassen ist
in der video mischling aber auch am ende
als erstes video gucken daumen nach oben
geben und dann das abschicken
und jetzt viel spaß so leute befasst
muss noch sagen wir wollen jetzt nicht
so dickere mädchen mit totalen dünnen
mädchen kontrastierend also die im
gegensatz zu stellen sondern einfach wir
fangen einfach mal an dann wisst ihr was
für nix angrenzende oder sonstwas okay
leute und zwar folgendes kennt ihr diese
diese hätten richtig klasse kennen diese
frauen beziehungsweise mädchen die sind
zum teil auch noch jünger die posten auf
instagram jeden tag zur fotos die sehen
wirklich richtig gut aus das ist nur das
ding ist die sind echt gar nicht so gut
aus
wisst ihr die machen das so wenn ihr zum
beispiel so eine pose haben dann posen
die da erstmal so die machen ohne scheiß
500 bilder bis ihr ein gutes bild haben
dass wir dann noch mal mit photoshop
bearbeitet und damit wirklich gut aus
nur das entspricht überhaupt nicht der
realität und diesen instagram fake
frauen
nein dann war dann halt mädchen dann
wollen halt mädchen deren figur jetzt zb
eigentlich gut ist aber die sagen ich
will auch so aussehen obwohl das gar
nicht funktioniert die wollen dann aber
auch so aussehen und sind damit sich
selber nicht mehr zufrieden
wisst ihr was ich meine genau das was er
glaube ich sagen will es einfach diese
diese leute die vorgeben wie die was die
perfekte figur ist diese teurem super
modell ist okay nächsten punkt
ein anderer punkt die jungs auch ein
bisschen gegängelt oder ein bisschen
unrealistisch finden sind diese
werbespot im fernsehen die irgendwie
sagen zu wollen drei wochen machen wir
dich super schlank sexy der körper noch
und du wirst 100 148 9 millionen 1000
kilo abnehmen weil man eigentlich mal
ganz ehrlich ist irgendwo das nichtmals
schaffen kann
egal wie sehr man sich da sicherlich
also nicht dass wir irgendetwas gegen
sowas haben aber ich finde diese art wie
diese werbung gemacht wird welche die
steifen warum kann man nicht einfach so
ich kenne einige die es geschafft hat
aber die leute die sich dann diese
instagram bilder angucken von so frauen
die total das ist alles fake die gehen
dann auch susan ein make you sexy dort
kommen
das ding ist einfach es gibt ja es gibt
ja immer im internet oder gerade in den
medien gibt's immer diese idealfigur
wovon alle menschen gerade sprechen und
ihr auch alle und wir erreichen wollen
aber das ding ist dass diese ideal
figuren die sind erst mal gar nicht
ideal weil das gerade für jeden jungen
irgendwie anders ist jeder sieht
natürlich anders für mich zum beispiel
ist es gar nicht so krass ideal wie
diese topmodels dieser figur haben von
ja genau jetzt wert wäre dass dieses
ideal gesetzt dass leute die jetzt nicht
so viel wiegen wie andere automatisch
immer perfekt jahr ebenso diese perfekt
sein
was alle anstreben was ist eigentlich
gern auch hier nicht so eine gute
meinung den sack mich zu ich auch und
gerade deswegen jetzt dafür auf einstige
und gerade gerade deswegen verstehe ich
nicht warum alle nach diesem diesem
diesem system gehen und alle so omaha hi
bred genau das würde ich mal sagen so
jetzt kommen wir zum vierten punkt in
dieser punkt ist könnt ihr diese
freundinnen die andere etwas auf
gefunkte freundinnen verfolgen ja nicht
ich find's einfach allgemein irgendwie
das ist halt allgemein so das ist immer
es gibt auch immer diese freundinnen wo
die extra somit etwas
das ist voll schwer ausdrücken es gibt
freundin von freundin und ihr habt den
image ihrer freundinnen indem ihr
einfach etwas besser aussehen
genau das wirklich so und was sagt ihr
zu ihrer umfrage sind es uns ist doch
besser wenn ihr jetzt meine kommentare
hier raus ihr darüber gehen schreibt ein
kommentar-feld
was hätte man sehe ich wollte hier endet
haben
was heißt die thematik kommentar hand
nehme ich jetzt auf jeden fall die
videos von den beinahe pleiten in der
video verlinkt abonniert und ja nicht
zufrieden wenn ihr das macht ansonsten
haben nichts denn mittwoch wieder über
390 beschuldigungen angenehm sonntag und
immer wieder